jalen says americans have experienced
current inflation rate in a long time
haven't experienced current inflation
rates in a long time a cnbc story many
firms are experiencing a shortage of uh
labor yellen says during an interview
with cnn sunday the covet shock to the
economy has caused disruptions that will
be working through over the next year
and of course americans haven't seen
inflation like we've experienced in a
long time host jake tapper
noted how inflation is growing at its
fastest pace in 30 years and ask whether
spending more money on biden's build
back better agenda will be pouring gas
on inflation fire prompting yellen to
say the spending on the bipartisan
infrastructure package and a massive
social spending package would be spread
out over the next decade tapper later
asked yelen when she expects the
inflation rate to return to two percent
levels which the federal reserve
classifies as acceptable she replied i
expect improvement by the middle of next
year
second half of uh next year is what
she's saying okay that that's her words
let me see if there's anything else
that's it okay i have two questions go
for it
question number one do you believe her
do i believe her what's she saying
absolutely not and question number two
do you believe that she believes what
she's saying uh
i actually think she does okay i
actually think she does because
uh i and this is a smart woman this is
not a person that hasn't been around
she's a small boy she's been done yeah
fair share i actually think she does and
i actually think a part of it is what
you're supposed to do to make the world
not panic and overreact because the last
thing they want is for people to stop
buying for people people to stop
spending for hoarding going back into
that mode no that is not a thing she
wants for the economy because that's not
her job now i called goldman sachs
yesterday
just to kind of find out what their
thoughts on what's going on i said so
what do you think is going to happen
with rates he says well pals already
said they're going up i said okay
uh what do you think is going to happen
with inflation it says it's here it's
not going away to control inflation the
way you do it is by increasing the rates
right so yes
say say hyperinflation goes okay you go
study jimmy carter today i did video
talking about is uh
is jimmy it's joe biden
jimmy carter 2.0 or much worse right and
we compared how many markers 10 markers
yes
on how inflation was how misery index
was and we compared from the beginning
of his administration to the time he
ended and we compared biden from the day
he got started to where it is today so
it's a very interesting thing inflation
during uh uh jimmy carter do you know
how i got
nearly 14 percent yeah okay during jimmy
carter interest rates were double digits
cds you could get a 16 cd talk about
save that money yeah 16 cd but it means
nothing if you're making 16 cd and
inflation is 14 percent you're only if
your mortgage is 12 percent that means
nothing so
here's
why
hyperinflation may not show up
this is when i when they say
hyperinflation may not show up here's
here's how i prone freshman i show up
hyperinflation may not show up but
10 15
interest rates may
before hyperinflation shows up they will
control it by banking interest rates 10
to 15 percent slamming the brakes
slamming the brakes at the highest level
listen pump the brakes don't go finance
anymore anymore if you can't afford a
million dollar home and you can't put 20
down guess what this ain't for you okay
no more five percent no more ten percent
none of this stuff just go back and buy
five hundred thousand dollar house and
come back three years later easy money
no free money the whole fake money the
easy money stuff because money is so
freaking cheap right now it's ridiculous
there is no charge there is a part of
you correct me if i'm wrong because with
all the printing and the fake success
cause you get worked up about this
there is a part of you that definitely
wants to see some things crumble
something's crap why would i want it
though tell me why i would want it
because you tell me how you've actually
made your success the right way yeah so
when you see fake success you're like
this but but let me ask you a question
let me ask you a question so why would i
want it unpack why would want it
why would you want why would i want that
to happen
just so reality comes back to normal i
think i mean you see a story out there
that you put a hundred dollars into
shibu inu some crypto coin now you're
worth a million bucks yeah something
ridiculous okay it's just so far-fetched
it's fake success it's fake money if you
made it the real way why would you want
fake the only the only time
where you would want something like this
to happen is sometimes we have to be
reminded
by reality hitting us yeah and it hasn't
hit america yet i also think it's a
restructuring
of the people who can and know how to do
it versus that's one area but to me to
me sometimes
look we can sit here and philosophically
talk about 93 keys to success and how to
do this with money and how to do that
with money
sometimes it's simplicity man it forces
you to go back to simple concepts this
is not about quantitative easing or qe
you know qovs or don't spend more than
you have
it just goes back to basics so america
needs to be humbled a little bit by the
economy and the way we're going right
now people are thinking this is going to
last forever we had a guy who we were
working at valleys we both leave valleys
i go to the insurance industry within
three years in the insurance industry
i'm barely making six figures a year
within three years in a mortgage
industry he's making 500k
per month wow we go to their month per
month i can i go to the bank
and i'm fighting b of a on a fee he's
two uh what do you call it uh
he's saying i'd like to deposit one
point three million dollars and and i
look at him i'm like
he looks at me says hey pat
that's my mother he just deposited 1.3
million just give me the points three
zero you know 30k what year is this this
is the 2004 2000 the 2000 uh 2005. first
and he's in the mortgage industry he's
in a mortgage
he's making 500k a month you know what
fake you know what happened to that guy
you know he had four rolls royces parked
outside
you know he says i need four different
color for rolls-royces living in all the
everything was financed guess what
happened you lost it all tax every
single thing yeah wiped out because that
was fake success
and fake success gets filtered out very
very quickly and it's going to happen
again but the direction we're going
right now when a jack dorsey says
something like this
and people say that'll never happen the
only reason i agree that hyperinflation
will never happen is because before
hyperinflation comes you're going to
experience 10 15 percent you'll see
there'll be 10 15 interesting there's
also something to be said about there's
so many people
that are
getting money or making money without
working right and here's my
let me just finish this and i'll go to
you
there's what happened to just hard work
in america i'm working my ass off i'm
working hard i'm working smart and these
i'm reaping the benefits of what i sow
now it's stimulus checks right just
unemployment it's crypto it's nft it's
whatever stock market it's my house just
appreciated 35
it's cash all cash buyers it seems a
little too good to be true so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]